Estados Unidos deriva el cuarto objeto
Volador y no ocho días Esta vez fue en
el lago uno en el domingo en la tarde
horas antes del Super Bowl según el
departamento de defensa se trataba de un
objeto no tripulado que no representaba
inicialmente una amenaza militar para
nadie en tierra las autoridades dijeron
que este objeto detectado inicialmente
el sábado por la noche volaba sin
embargo sobre la Península superior de
Michigan a unos 20.000 pies de altitud
una altitud que preocupaba sobre todo
por una posible interferencia con la
Aviación comercial en este sentido el
pentágono optó por derivarlo después de
rastrearlo sobre el Lago Superior hurón
el aumento de la destrucción de este
tipo de objetos se produce también
cuando oficiales militares
estadounidenses han estado examinando
más de cerca los cielos de Estados
Unidos tras el derivo del primer globo
en Carolina del Sur que las autoridades
pues ya han dicho se trataba de un globo
chino que trataba de quedarse con
información confidencial militar de
Estados Unidos